hi everybody
[Applause]
gosh is this um and allison olivia
is i've i've tried to really think about
what you would want me to be in
how i could like appeal to you the most
and i went with the daisies
i love it that's my favorite flower well
i sort of looked that up
[Laughter]
that well stacy yes um
stacy bennett who created alice and
olivia is someone i know and she texted
me saying
that you guys were gonna dress for the
show and i was so
thrilled well she says us because it's
plural because she really does dress me
she tells me what i'm wearing i call her
the fashion dictator
i have to do what she says said by the
woman who created dictator lunches one
of my favorite instagram accounts
thank you and we did that show still
think about
syringing yogurt into fruit every time i
think about you i love that
i know what an odd association right but
i also think of just like goodness
and humor and beauty and a good marriage
and so sweet thank you how do you keep
it fun
and funny and rolling with jayden who
you with jaden
i always think it's a like a typo and
then i'm like no she really does call
him jayden
well i like to call him jaden my phone
actually started it my phone would
autocorrect
jason to jaden they would always say oh
you must mean jaden
if you're writing the word jason which i
i thought that jason was at least
in the 80s one of the more common names
you could give somebody
yeah my phone insists that it's they
just gives it an extra flair so
not xanther right jason
we've got two on the set right here we
have only a few people
right yeah yeah you always have a
handful of jason's in a room
so i would write jason and the phone was
like jaden and then i started doing it
because i'm always referred to as jason
biggs's wife
and i liked it because it's sort of my
way of like being a little disrespectful
to him
and sort of like putting him in his
place because it's like known
on my instagram like you're my husband
so you're jaden it's so cute i just love
the
another issue he has with me i mean
you guys have also found a great way to
laugh through parenting and
you've talked about this yes like how do
you guys
handle it all how do you find the humor
how do you tag team
well i like to play little pranks on the
kids i think it's sort of fun to just
keep
i want them to have a good sense of
humor i want them to realize that you
know comedy is important and to just
be able to laugh your way through it so
sometimes you know my son
my eldest will be spinning out about
something recently he discovered that
our dog is chipped and he was just like
my god you know
what do you mean there's a chip under
her skin and i said well yes it's so
that we can find her if she gets lost we
also put one in you when you were born
and he was just like are you
kidding me you know and so i told him i
was kidding
by the way if you could chip your kid
would you
well i did look into it when i first had
a kid
when i first got when i always say when
i first got them like as if i bought
them at the store i was like
when i first got you uh yeah no i was
interested i'm like
how will i let you out of my sight like
how could i deal with you out in the
world and i'm not
sort of watching over you uh is there
something that i could maybe
tag you with yeah maybe not a chip but
you know like when a shark comes by when
they're like tagging sharks and they
like have a
little it's like an earring they wear
yes
yes it falls off over time i could be
cool with that
all right well what are you and jason up
to now like how's everything going
what's going on in the home
bring us into fly on the wall moment at
like this wonderful home of yours
well we're dealing today jason texted me
to remind me i said
you know you got to remind me what did
sid say why because we considered
getting a dog
over uh the quarantine yeah and he has
these little stuffed animals that he
calls babas
and so i was asking the boys do you want
to rescue this dog
there's this little rescue poodle i'm
thinking about bringing him home
and sid looks at me he's like i don't
know i mean i just got a new baba
i'm like are you kidding me so jason and
i were
texting me to be satisfied he's like
remember when he said that he doesn't
want a dog he also just told me this
morning
i'm the main character in this house
so we may not be doing everything right
i don't know if you guys should take
parenting advice from us at all
to be honest like i am the lead
jenny mullen follow her on instagram
jenny mullen and dictator lunches
two of my favorite accounts